bist du zufrieden mit seinem leben eine
relativ einfache frage immerhin online
ich will nicht die antwort hallo ich
meine liebe freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einer runde super jobs zusammen mit
tatkraft und geräten über das thema
kindheit will den fortschritt den wir
suchen uns ein super tolles thema aus
und zwar ist unser thema kein geringeres
als das thema des jahres und thw ist das
thema des jahres
ach du schaffst das schon so schnell her
denn ich mache das hier alles immer auf
nummer sicher so ein bisschen dadurch
trotzdem runter gefallen weil ich dich
dann am horizont erblickt habe ich bin
abgehört ich stehe jetzt zurück horrillo
ist viel weiter als ich wir können uns
tatsächlich ein cooles thema aussuchen
und zwar wir reden über das super tolle
thema redet man über themen
wir reden über das t home entertain
redet wir reden über das thema themen
wochen sind eine krasse sache
themen sind sachen um sich den zeit zu
verstehen zu genau vertreiben er
vertraglich sozusagen die zeit damit
indem wir uns zuhört wie wir uns die
zeit vertreiben
ja deswegen das ist richtig krass
vertreibt erwarteten wieder könnte ich
das
ihr hört uns quasi zu wir brauchen ein
anderes thema das bringt mich zum
wahnsinn ich hab das internet bietet
hiermit mit mit fragen und geben
menschen freuen können vielleicht kann
man die auch auf uns beide beziehen
nein wir brauchen irgend ein cooles
thema ich weiß doch weißt als wir
zusammen im urlaub waren mit den anderen
wo wir was du dabei als wir vor der vor
der disco lassen und dabei etwas
diskutiert haben und dann kam so ein typ
ohne spaß von typ kam zu uns an und
meinte hey ihr hat super gedanken zu dem
thema ich gebe euch mal hier meine
visitenkarte und das beste sie altert
nein ich stand gerade auf diesem letzten
sounder da war ich glaub ich nicht dabei
wo wo bist du das mal wieder habt acht
gegen halb acht gemessen ich habe wir
wollen jetzt einfach eine runde panda so
vor wir zu basic themen besprechen wenn
ich hab mir das nicht so fragen stellen
das ja ich habe in letzter zeit immer so
richtig krasse themen beantwortet okay
machen irgendwas was sehen werden und
zwar apple oder android vor allem ich
denke in so was interessiert die leute
auch einfach am meisten oder nicht was
meine meinung ist dazu das flugzeug
abgestürzt oder so höchstwahrscheinlich
flugzeug meine meinung wer braucht
flugzeug eine bombe aus wie der junge
ich lass mir total die zeit machst
einfach durch
jetzt ist lukas macht auch mal schnell
an apple oder android oder machen wir
stellen ich frage anders erst mal die
folge sollten nicht langweilen sondern
ich nehme apple auf jeden fall die apple
apple viel einfacher bei mir wenn du
jetzt die ein handy überlegen ist das
was du dir ganz
aber so eine geburt sagte er könne nicht
ruhig brennerei ruf an ihm habe ich ein
scheitern kann uns ja gar nicht sehen
ich säge roddick sollte so also auch
wenn ihr handy handy auf jeden fall
apple und auch pc auf jeden fall apple
weil android pc
ich weiß aber nicht also ich würde mir
wahrscheinlich oder ich glaube ich würde
mir 15 können weil das ding ist einfach
wasser fällt
stell dir vor du kannst beim duschen
kannst du einfach sein leitungsnetz
junge beim duschen das also dass der
oder spaß das wäre schon grund sich
dafür zu ende schreiben ja ich liebe
dich oder spaßbad ist der so cool du
schon recht so geil will es wichtig die
man sich wirklich wie lange schon nicht
ich hab auf vier minuten ich wollte
richtig so lange halten ich wollte euch
nur passieren hier beruhigen dann kann
man vielleicht mein bester feind machen
wenn ein paar kurze karten ausspielen
ok ja was moment macht bin ich wieder so
irgendwas stadt vielleicht habe ich noch
so ein anderes thema diese
lieblingsfrage einziehen youtube
wie bist du zum letztlichen gekommen die
beantworten weshalb willst du mal in der
zukunft fantreffen machen oder ist es
nicht so einfach werde ich nicht mal ich
werde auf jeden fall also wenn ihr euch
jetzt denkt dass maxi dies beantwortet
maxime doppelte zeit nicht mit auf also
max wird ja auch gleich noch antworten
aber jedenfalls ich bin total nicht der
fan von fans retten
bist du denn nicht der fan von treffen
genau das meine ich weiß nicht ich mag
es gar nicht wenn da so ganz viele leute
sind die sind alle nur wegen mir wert
bei anderen leute wenn ich das mache
dann werde ich möchte auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen heruntergefallen alter wie
ich das land ist ja ganz super gut
vorstellen also bei mir ist ja so ich
habe jetzt bei weitem nicht so viele
abonnenten wie luca und ich werde sogar
ab und zu schon mal erkannt so auf der
straße und luca wird durch so auf der
straße erkannt wenn ihr dann fantreffen
macht
randy dem den kopf ein und so also ich
kann es teilweise auch recht verstehen
es gibt immer noch leute die viel größer
sind als einer da gibt's dann ja die
ganz anderen aus köln
aber ich hatte auch schon als ich
einfach mal durch köln durch gelaufen
bin kam da wirklich einfach so zehn
leute an
an einem tag und wollten dann irgendwie
autogrammen deswegen habe ich auch total
1 bei seinen fans treffen vor allem dass
wenn ich dann weg fahren mit dem auto
oder einfach nicht so schlimm denn wenn
die einem hinterher auch ja und dann
wissen die wo du wohnst und alles nichts
gegen euch aber es gibt wirklich so ein
paar leute die sind die nehmen das ganze
viel zu sehr zu herzen und setzen ihr
leben daran alles über ein
herauszufinden was es gibt
ich weiß es von einem anderen youtuber
ich will jetzt nicht sagen wer aber ich
nicht fest ob er das möchte dass das
sage aber ich bin auf jeden fall verbot
letztens zu hause privat angerufen von
jemandem gesagt hat her bin ich da mit
dem man dem verbunden und da ging dann
die mutter daran halte dann so einfach
nein und soll da rufen dann schauen die
leute zu hause an alltag bei franck hat
man anhand der fenster marke da
angerufen und hat gefragt ob mir die
fenster verkauft wurden obwohl der name
von bronk durchgegeben und die adresse
was diese analysiert die sagen dem die
namen ja klar wenn sich irgendwelche
hardcore fans dann ausgeben als wenn sie
die reparieren müssten oder irgendwie
sowas und die adresse irgendwie sowas
keine ahnung warum verstehe ich auch
nicht aber so krasser leute gibt es
freunde das muss man so ich schaffe
diesen sprung ich das muss man einfach
sagen das ist schon heftig einfach
deswegen ich würde diesen fantreffen
alleine machen
ich will auf jeden fall so video day
oder so david kong oder so gamescom so
ein paar sachen darf ich auf jeden fall
hin aber sondern so ein fantreffen
alleine machen
wer dich wirklich 40 wirklich einfach
aus dem grund dass mir jemand folgt
entwickelt deshalb willkommen wie so ein
paar youtuber ich glaube das waren auch
unter anderem revier otp ist und so
haben das gemacht und dann sind sie
einfach in einem taxi abgehauen
einfach weil so viele leute dort waren
und dann muss man einfach abhauen
das ist ja auch da irgendwie recht nicht
mehr cool wenn mal gar nix das reh und
rotwild schon machen müssen stemmer vor
irgendwie dena und simon würden zusammen
vertreter machen
dass das wäre nicht mehr normal dass
vielleicht eine massenpanik an der
tabelle gleich denken auch manchmal
es ist zwar echt cool so viele
abonnenten zu haben wie das leuchtend
wie zum beispiel ja genau wie zum
beispiel den alles jemand aber es ist
auch wirklich ein krasser preis den man
zahlen muss
mein tipp du gibst ja sozusagen dein
privatleben dafür auf vor allem bei den
von ihm weiß man alles das ist ehrlich
und dadurch dass man das er als sein
seinen echten namen wie ein bisschen
preisgegeben hatte
das wollte er sogar nicht mal das ist
außerdem geschehen persönlich und dann
hat er seine einfach so beibehalten
das ist echt heftig also teilweise
befall unsere meinung zu helfen auch
wenn ich auf irgendwelchen seiten rum
stolpe mit fan fiction und so ich denke
manchmal einfach fan fiction vor schluss
hat denke ich mir warum denkt man sich
sowas auswendig da so hardcore-fans
ebene vor allem wenn ich eine freundin
hätte was wird denn denken wenn der deal
ist dass diese studie junge land
schreiben da irgendwelche hardcore
girlies ja er küsste wir über den nacken
und alle sind an der ina jung ist so
eine scheiße weg kommt denn auf so was
das ist die hänge mit pikanten weise so
ein bisschen bei dem hack mittel junge
ich strenge mich jetzt an wenn ich den
sport schaffe dann direkt mit notarzt
überlebte weil die ampel an
ich bin noch nie so schnell die hilfen
gut ich mache das immer so ohne stopp
und mit diesem es gibt diese sprint
taste eine gasse belegen machst du das
oder wie auch immer noch mit
doppel-champion papier station
kostenvorteile durch das anders machst
du im pvp werde ich nie in vorteil
erringen können wörter wenn ihr wollt
dass wir immer an 20 stunden pvp stream
machen
wir haben schon mal sagen ja wenn ihr
bestes internet ab heute habe ich gar
nix mehr
das war eine kleine mal wieder machen
hatte ich bin ja ich habe einen guten
lauf ich habe einen guten lauf duca 1
grad ich habe keine ahnung wo ich jetzt
gerade bin okay ich bin kurz hofft hier
ja okay ich es geschafft
das hat gescheppert alter
immer so angestrengt sache gehen wir ach
ja ich bin schon richtig nicht ich bin
doch nicht da
hallo frage irgendwas kurzen nochmal
irgendwo ein die wir schon mal so machen
jetzt auch schon einfach nur mal so
jetzt gewinnt er hat ein pferd alles
jetzt gewonnen ach du meinst doppelt
oder nicht oder
der zehnfache oder nächstes einfach
immer so frame einbrüche dass wikileaks
dies so zufrieden mit seinem leben eine
relativ einfache frage immerhin online
die antwort das war nicht die antwort
auf die frage mein heim oder was würdest
du verändern wenn du könntest verletzt
ausgeschieden luca ich will kommt schon
wieder an gesprintet alter überholt die
nochmal karstadt kommt kaum schock
konnte
und da ist der martha fucking sich diese
schreibe ich dann nicht diesen ekligen
leiter sprung der vollkommen
verantworten die frage ich bin
eigentlich wirklich zufrieden mit meinem
leben ich muss sagen es hätte ich auch
total anders kommen können man hätte
auch einfach im pelz eintagsfliege
werden können oder wenn wir direkt oder
man hätte ja auch gegen bundesautobahnen
hast du sagst dass du keine
eintagsfliege ist dies oder oder oder
stell mal vor so die abo wind
okay vielleicht selber vor du wird es
wirklich so in so starten geboren werden
wo kinder aber einfach völlig normal für
die kindheit hat halt ist schon gehen
wir können richtig froh sein wir sind in
einem der sichersten länder der welt
aufgewachsen und alles
man kann richtig richtig froh sein also
wenn ich stolz auf seinen leben ist wenn
ich froh was erleben ist dagegen was
falsch
da muss man so wenn man das urteil muss
man das so sagen aber wenn wir jetzt mal
davon ausgeht dass der standard ist dass
man so aufwächst dann würde ich sogar
sagen ja wir ja auch zufrieden weil ich
youtube und mittelgroße möglichkeit
gegeben hat ich beispielsweise
studienfinanzierung und alles mögliche
stimmt es echt schon ziemlich geil hat
das also personen neue leute kennen wir
als alles das schon ganz cool ich find's
cool also das ist wirklich ein tolles
hobby youtube beziehen dass sie also auf
youtube aber allgemein wenig zufrieden
bist du bei youtube besser leben mit auf
jeden fall
ok ich glaube das war da noch die letzte
frage wollten technisch so super lang
machen dann für and mal ein video poker
ja ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat
diesen super job wenn die eventuell mehr
superjob wollt dann max dann schreibt es
in einem brief an eure großeltern
genommen dass es die sache was man
machen sollte und die schreib seien die
kommentare so kann die like nur noch das
video wilhelm kramer in der beschreibung
wenn ich nicht vergessen wir sehen uns
eher heißt kran crafter tv ohne tv aber
ohne tv hat das heißt nur minecraft so
heißt dich auf ihren seiten wo mir der
name geklaut wurde stimmte twitter